allora ragazzi il video di oggi è
parecchio sta non è vero non gas è
normale faccio una partita incredibile
tanto per cambiare perché sennò non ve
le porto le partite sono tutti
incredibili perché alle volte il regista
partite brutte non le metto quindi sono
tutte belle e inutile lo dico sempre
parlate visto video ma che è incredibile
è incredibile come gli altri quindi
buona visione
[Musica]
poi riservati mamma mia
un sacco di tempo che non gioco con
buddy andiamo lì sotto vito a fare
quella roba della carta che non sto
facendo ma semplicemente per depistare
un po lalagia la gente
vediamo se qualcuno viene in elettrica
per caso se c'è già qualcuno in
elettrica c'è già così elettrica quindi
report o niente
quindi non è trovato loco e dell'energia
andando a fare una tasca del della ii
morto
ok videro mi ha visto anche march per
cece raga fabio pulito sono entrati a
milano la rai ragazzi quando ragazzo
parla march è sempre stato infatti
spiega pulito automatico io mi sono
marci con juno mia stima l'ance pulito
raga ma vi giuro
allora votiamo march non è immaginato
tempo bene bene così bravi ragazzi bravi
anche noi ha detto è palese favi quindi
io adesso ti all emergency poteri che
noia che noia perché perché ha detto
palese fabi dopo che io ho detto che il
march non era march mi ha difeso quindi
io non sono perché lui non è impostore
che non ha senso se muoio e lorenzo ok a
torino nata non abbiamo rimpianti viola
schifo però comunque sbagliato sarò raga
voluto non sanno giocare ragazzi c'è
porco demonio non sanno giocare
adesso dobbiamo quanto si può usare 8
secondi 7 6 5 4 3 2 r atto ok perfetto
di qualcun estratto influenza ma cosa
succede
ma cosa sto vedendo penso anch'io no tu
no sento anch'io stiamo entrando tutti i
biglietti e poi a matteo da questo
genere è una cosa sì ma cosa avrebbe ma
perché ma cos'è che partita è cosa vedo
la cosa si farà
tutto bene tutto bene ragazza sorridente
[Musica]
aula stimo verdi non sono mai stato
verde in un bambino da quando esiste
penso come lei però di fare med e med
meta ed è una vita che non faccio med se
sarà provato due volte alla mia vita ed
io l'hanno cambiata non era così anno
era questa cosa che facevo io teca
branks cacchio ago grava kof
eppure è difficile ci metti pure un
sacco di tempo a far emerge allora ma
due morti così a garanzia del corpo
skype che dobbiamo fare l'altro lo
studente è morto brano però ogni giorno
estranea per il maestro fatto che sia
morto va bene io non ho capito se sapete
che non ve lo giuro su dio ve lo giuro
raga io non ho mai fatto stata la prima
volta è la prima volta che faccio stata
skinhead non mi è mai successo di fare
una task in med
cioè mi è successo di fare gola dello
scanno ma non mi è mai successo di fare
questa ora hanno aggiunta è nuova oppure
non mi era mai capitata quindi una
coincidenza incredibile no mica
sabotaggio di che cosa coms io vuol dire
salire com sab hotels cosa diavolo è
ragazzi step
sapete perché stesso perché quando parla
tanto è perché deve uscire bel video e
quindi esterne sta parlando solo terzo
se ci fate caso sta parlando solo stef
quindi deve uscire un buon video quasi
quasi non li non dico niente perché il
rilascio del vino e lo lascio fa nel
video mystère
vi assicuro che uno e stef l'altro non
so se che noia potrebbe essere anno 80
benevento non soltanto non 70 perfetto
però uno chef al 200 per cento ragazzi
ho finito le tasche come mio solito e
nessuno 400 sta giocando lo vedo nessuno
sono tutti a security ragazzi non vedono
e non c'è nessuno che sta giocando dalla
mia parte c'era non me non ho incontrato
una persona e due ore come non c'è la
gente non esiste la gente dove a del tuo
di report e sui morti tutti pesante mai
a chi è chiamato cosa io ho trovato un
corpo di che noia quindi ragazzi fate un
attimo uno più uno per favore dato che
siamo solo in cinque allora io ero con
che noia e che la morte non era ci siamo
uccisi è una cosa io ero in telecamere e
stanno spiando the martina e marone va
ben otto secondi giusti ferme al
download quindi stavo per dire riguarda
che a martina e pulita l'avete uccisa
per me lorenzo aia per esclusione
wattaggi cosa che telecamere guardato
però seri di fianco a me non ti potevo
vedere che ha visto che ero lì il
reattore
ahia ahia ahia ahia fiori dell'era
abbiamo perso se doveva fabio lagorai a
ragazzi di luigi direttore io prima che
si chiudesse la prima cosa ho detto
ragalo secondo me e buddy
programmi ha tranciato la testa i
ragazzi questo episodio di lunga di oggi
spero vi sia piaciuto assolutamente non
mi piace e noi come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo
[Musica]